[Music]
foreign
as you can see here you'll see the
suspect turn and point her firearm at
our officers there's this picture
and then one additional where the
handgun is directly pointing towards our
brave officer
[Music]
thank you
you can see how she's running with the
handgun in her hand while the officer
tries to de-escalate by giving her
commands to drop it
you can also see over here the handgun
is still in her hand as she points it at
her officer and it solely falls out of
her hands after
there's a picture of the handgun that
she's running with
here's the picture of her pointing the
handgun at our officer
and there's a picture of it still in her
hand from his point of view
and that's the picture of the firearm as
it fell to the ground